turned out live let's talk about that I
mean you go just shortly after you did
your did you work for us if you went to
send out live and you did an audition
those are famously tough auditions you
got Lauren Michaels sitting there you
got all these writers and producers
sitting there are we gonna pick for the
cast what did you do how did you prepare
for your audition uh I just went in
there and I was like ma'am I'm gonna do
what I've been doing on the road
and what I've been doing on the road was
a bunch of crackhead material so I did I
talked about crackheads see my uncle was
a crackhead we'd even know at first we
just thought it was a fun dude because
you don't know what crack is you a kid
you don't know what crack is you know
you just first record I saw he was like
yeah we're gonna get everything we want
to get today's the day man today is a
day hey man that was the same dude but
la like LA has like weirder crack is in
Chicago we have come to the criminal
records right but like LA they're weird
out here man because they're like I feel
like it's because they came out here for
a dream and it found crack you know they
came out here maybe to be an actor
pursue show business and then they got
sidetracked yeah so the so they
approached the crackhead lifestyle just
a little more presentation like I was on
Hollywood Boulevard and this crackhead
stopped me and was like hey brother pick
a card any card and he didn't have any
cards in his I was like there's no car
to your hand man and he looked me dead
in my eyes was like tada
that's not magic you're unprepared did
you ever see that guy again no I did I
literally did like two weeks later I saw
the same dude right I put that knock
right away I saw these two girls one
girls having a birthday and she was like
it's my birthday well she was a little
drunk and her friend was helping her
walk like yes Rebecca it's your birthday
now use your legs girl and then as
they're walking past this bushes magical
crackhead jumped out the bushes I don't
know how long he had been sitting in it
I would guess all day yeah as soon as
they walked past he jumped out he's like
don't nobody give a damn about sober and
then he walked back in the bushes just
walk back in like that Homer mean he
doesn't walk back I've never seen a
grown man walk back in some bushes like
he had other stuff to do I had so many
questions I asked him something but I
wasn't going in those bushes right
that's ridiculous right so I stood
outside the bushes I said the one thing
I could think of the give me paw Paw's I
was like oh it's my birthday too
I thought that was his trigger right and
and all he said from the bushes was no
it ain't all he said was tada but you
yeah you gotta love that guy I do I love
him I'm not left him some money to like
a make sure you use it for food he'll
come back out
you